and um uh so
our first speaker today looks like it
will be susanna
uh out of order so uh but we're very
pleased to have her here
uh susana received her phd i think in
2019
is that correct and uh has been working
improve complexity
and especially i'd say in lower bounds
for
proof in propositional logic and
propositional systems
uh so it's a pleasure to have her here i
don't have the title of her talk in
front of me but she'll post it in a
moment
and uh please go ahead
okay well thanks a lot sam and uh yeah
thanks for inviting me
to talk so
so yes i'll be talking about connections
between uh
proofs and circuits
and i'd like to start with uh motivating
our
motivating problem which we'll come back
to
throughout this talk so this is the
click coloring principle
so a k minus one colorable graph does
not contain okay click so here we have
an example this is a three color vocal
graph
and it clearly does not contain uh a
four click
we'll consider uh the click sorry
what do you mean clearly it's a joke
right
it's recolorable sorry mean
yes it's three colorful so it does not
contain a four click
so so we'll consider the
click coloring function so this is a
partial function
which receives as input a graph and
it outputs one if the graph has a k
click
and it outputs zero if the graph is k
minus one colorable
uh and we don't care what it outputs uh
otherwise
and the question we're interested in is
how hard is it to compute
this function okay so
one observation is that well click
coloring is easier
to compute then click so in particular
the click function
that outputs one if and only if there is
a k click
is uh um
is also satisfies the click coloring
function
requirements and uh another observation
is that well we actually know that click
coloring is in
polynomial time uh this is by the lowest
data function
so when i say how hard is it to compute
clear coloring i mean in some
restricted model of computation okay
so this is one object we'll be
considering the click coloring function
the other one is the click coloring
formula so this formula
has uh two parts it has the click part
so x here uh these variables are
encoding
the edges of a graph and this formula
is stating that the the graph encoded by
the x
variables actually has a k click so this
first part encodes
that there are k distinct elements that
form the click
and this third line encodes that there
is an edge between any two distinct
elements of the click then there's the
coloring part which encodes that the
the graph given by x has a
k minus one coloring so this the first
part encodes that every vertex has a
color
and the second line that uh
two vertices with the same color cannot
be connected by an edge
okay so clearly uh
click and color is unsatisfiable
so here we're interested in how hard is
it to
refute this this formula
okay okay so this is the plan for the
talk so we'll be
talking about proofs circuits and
communication protocols
uh i'll first explain what i mean by
communication
and how it relates to circuits so we'll
see that these objects are in some sense
the same then i'll
explain what the interpolation method is
so related to our problem this will
explain why the fact that click
coloring is hard to compute implies that
k coloring is hard to prove
and for this we'll see that from how
from a small proof
we can obtain a small circuit or
also from a small proof we can obtain a
small communication protocol
and then i'll talk about lifting
theorems so this
lifting theorems would explain why the
fact that pigeonhole principle
is hard to prove implies that click
coloring is hard to compute
so this gives relations in the other
direction
and and then finally i'll state some
open problems okay
so this is the plan for the talk
so okay i'll talk about boolean circuits
so just circuits and or
not gates um i'll sometimes refer to
specifically to monotone circuits and
i'll talk about both the size of the
circuit and the depth
and i'll use this notation circuit f
just to denote the size of the smallest
circuit computing now
okay so communication uh we we have two
players
they each have uh an input so alice
receives an input x bob receives an
input y
and their goal is to compute a function
on their
joint input so in order to do this they
communicate by sending
bits to each other
we can view this communication process
as a protocol
which was a tree-like protocol like this
the load nodes are labeled by who is
speaking
and if we view the possible inputs
as a matrix we can also view this this
protocol
as a tree where at every node we have
some combinatorial rectangle which is
the
possible inputs to alice in corresponds
to the possible inputs to alice and bob
that are
that are compatible with this this node
okay and the reason i wanted to
show this this view where we have the
rectangles is because with this view
it's easy to see
how we can define a dag-like protocol
so a dag-like protocol well yeah we have
a dac
at the at the roots we have the complete
combinatorial rectangle corresponding to
all possible alice and bob's inputs
and every we have the the requirements
that
for every node in this in this stack
the combinatorial rectangle of
compatible inputs is covered
by the children okay
so by dag
cc of f i mean the size of the smallest
dag-like protocol that computes so in
order to relate
these objects to circuits cosmere and
victor's and define this game
uh so we'll call it crash the kw game
so here alice so we have some function
alice receives an input in the pre-image
of one
bob receives an input in the pre-image
of zero
and these inputs are clearly different
so their goal is to just
find a position where their inputs
differ
okay this is the kw game on f and
there's also a monotone version of this
game
where their goal is to find
uh input where alice has a one and bob
has a zero
and okay this only makes sense if f is
is monotone if f is monitoring we're
guaranteed that such
uh that such uh position exists
okay so with this game uh customer
victorson showed that actually circuits
and the communication protocols that
solve this game
are actually equivalent so the size of
the
dag-like communication protocol solving
the
kw game on f is the same as the size of
the
minimal circuit computing app
and the same holds for the monotone
version so
the size of the smallest stag-like
communication protocol solving the
monotone kw game on f
is the same as the size of the smallest
monotone circuit computing now
so this gives uh this relation between
communication protocols
and circuits
okay so let's
now take a look at crycek's
interpolation method
uh so we already saw how circuits relate
to communication so now how do proofs
come into play
so how do from proofs um how can we get
a circuit
so this is the interpolation method is
away from
from proofs of certain type formulas we
can we can get a
interpolant circuit uh but perhaps a
more natural way of viewing this is how
from
proofs we can get a communication
protocol for
this falsified clause search problem
which i'll define
next and from from this communication
protocol it's
easier to translate to the communication
problem for the kwk
okay so
uh proves the communication protocol
so our goal is to promise from a small
proof
obtain a small protocol
so suppose we're we have some formula
someone satisfiable formula f
so we can define this this uh problem
the
falsified clause search problem which is
we're
somehow given an assignment to to the
variables
and our goal is to find some clause that
is falsified by this assignment
and such a clause must exist because the
formula is unsatisfiable
and now in order to make this into a
communication game we have to somehow
split
the the inputs between the players
between alice and bob
so for example here we can split alice
receives
x and y bob received said and now they
have to
communicate in order to figure out which
which clause is
is falsified and it's not very hard to
see that you can actually
use this this a small proof to obtain
a small protocol that solves the problem
the main idea is that
uh if you're resolving over a variable x
there is some player that has the
silence of that variable
and he can decide which direction to
consider in the
in in the proof
okay so this so we just saw how from
resolution reputation we can obtain
a communication protocol and now let's
see a
big view of what um cry checks
in particular the monotone interpolation
method is for resolution
so here we're given a formula where
which has two parts a and b the only
variables in common are the x variables
and it has this special property that
either the x variables only appear
positively
in a or only negatively in b
or both so for example the click
coloring formula
satisfies this property and click x only
appears positively and in color x
only appears negatively
so if we're given such a formula we can
define
this function which depends on this
formula
uh it's a partial function and it's
1 if given an x
if a of x y is satisfiable and it's zero
if
b of x said is satisfiable
so from a communication protocol that
solves this falsified clause search
problem
we can obtain a communication protocol
that solves the monotone kw game for
this function
and now we know that by the kw relation
that this is
actually equal to the monotone
circuit complexity of the function
so if we have a lower bound in the
monotone circuit complexity
we actually get a low about lower bound
for the size of resolution refutations
so this is how for the click coloring
function
since first we had a proof
first we had a lower bound for monotone
circuits and this way we were
able to translate them into lower bounds
in proof complexity
okay so this is the uh interpolation
method for resolution
but they're also uh for other proof
systems so
for example for uh cutting planes so
padlock had a very nice application of
this interpolation method where
instead of monotone boolean circuits had
a stronger monotone real circuits
uh but this was for many years the only
method of proving lower bounds for for
cutting planes
more recently this was generalized
for not only for these formulas that are
the split like formulas
but also for for other formulas you can
also apply this interpolation method
and and in this way um
uh luck obtains lower bounds for bit
pigeonhole principle
and these two also for logins random
cnfs
and then there also interpolation for
several other
proof systems not by boolean circuits
but by other
computational models
okay so this is for interpolation
and now i'd like to talk a little bit
about lifting
so this is the picture
we saw so far and now we'll see how from
communication protocols we can
obtain proofs
so going back to our motivating problem
so we had this uh click coloring
function um
and as i mentioned so there were from
the
from the 80s there were already lower
bounds for
for the click function and these also
hold for the click coloring
so the first uh super polynomial lower
bound for monotone
circuits uh shown by raspberrov for the
click function so
you should enter the k for k up to log n
then along the generalized this for
larger values of k a lower bound of n to
the square root k
and very recently this was strengthened
to enter the k lower bound for k up to
n to the one third
so this is monotone circuit size lower
bounds there were
there are also proofs of monotone
circuit depth lower bounds so there's a
simple proof of
depth square root k
and then there's a proof of
k lower bound for k up to n over two
and now i don't know you might have
noticed that well actually
these size lower bounds also give that
lower bounds and they give
stronger depth lower bounds of the type
k over log n
but only for k up to
like n to the one third and for example
this the rasvigne actually gives you for
larger values of k and
by lifting we can also actually obtain
the optimal
depth lower bound for linear
up to linear values of k so what i'd
like to show
is that we can actually prove these two
results
by lifting pigeonhole principle
okay
susannah yes question yes
the depth floor bounds are those for for
clique or clique coloring or what
they they uh i think
they're all stated for click but they
also hold for click coloring
okay good thanks
okay so in order to explain
uh lifting i'll just have to say what uh
composition with a gadgeted
gadget is and so if you were
um i think a couple of weeks ago robert
gave
a talk about lifting where he explained
a bit about how lifting works so
just go over this quickly so there's so
we have
uh like when we were talking about the
search problem and we wanted to make
this into
a communication problem we split the
variables between alice and bob
but another way of making this into a
communication problem is to compose with
a gadget
so here we have some gadgets which
receives as input
x and y variables and
and alice receives the x variables bob
receives the y variables
and for each z variable we have some
independent
x and y that we apply the gadgets to
and obtain the value for for that
variable set
so let's see one specific example of a
gadget which we'll be using
so this is the indexing gadget so here
bob receives a very long string of zeros
and ones
for so he receives one string per per
z variable and alice receives
one pointer per z variable
and the output of the indexing gadget is
simply the bit that is pointed to by
alice
so if she points to a one then the
output is one
okay so this is the the gadget we'll be
we'll be considering
so let's see some some lifting theorem
so there are
many different lifting theorems i'll
just state um
some of them here so we have um
the raz mckenzie lifting theorem which
was
brought to light again by gospitasi
watson
so here we're obtaining a communication
depth lower bound
by lifting
depth decision tree or resolution depth
lower amount
there's also the size lower bound
version which was proved
more recently so this this lifting
theorem uh
also applies for a more general
communication model and
you can also get lower bounds for
cutting planes via this lifting
so here we can get size lower bounce for
dag-like communication by with lower
bounds for resolution
okay and this is the lifting theorem
that gives us the click coloring lower
bound
size lower bound that we saw earlier
and then there's also this other lifting
theorem which has a slightly different
flavor so here we're also getting a
uh well this is a specific uh case of
uh of the lifting theorem we also get a
depth lower bound but we're lifting
no still inside degree okay the
advantage of this lifting theorem is
that it doesn't only hold for
indexing it actually holds for any
gadgets and
in many cases you can even have constant
size gadgets
so you can get better results in some
cases using this so
using this lefty lifting theorem you can
get the
depth lower bound for click coloring
that i mentioned earlier
but let's focus now on this size lower
bound
do you have a question i could ask again
questions just to clarify
so you're talking about death dt that's
the decision tree
depth did you yes yes so
so as perhaps specifically thinking of
the case where s is the search problem
then this is just the resolution yeah
this is just the resolution depth but
otherwise it's the depth of the
the decision tree that is solving this
problem by querying
variables
okay that
so okay
does that make sense or no yeah
yeah i'm actually wondering for general
problem what is the width dt
for a general problem right so so you
can think of a
um a decision tree that can only
remember
the variables queried
so at every node it contains an
assignment that it remembers to certain
variables
and the width is the number of variables
that it
remembers at every node so you look at
the overall nodes
the node that remembers the you can
forget also
you can also forget exactly okay thanks
so so the comments on the right hand
side or the screen are meant to be
sort of easy to to check it's like easy
to see the depth dt of s
is depth res of of f is that
is that an easy thing to prove uh so if
you're looking at the search problem
yes yeah uh it's it's not hard to see
but but yeah you you can think of a
resolution
refutation as uh solving this falsified
clause search problem
right and and then you just have to
check that actually you get
exactly the the same thing right
okay yeah
okay
and the the rank of rank of g on the
third one what is that
all right so this this is uh so you can
view the gadget so
that gadget receives the x and y so you
can view it as
a matrix and it's the
rank of this matrix
okay uh uh and jakob has a comment here
i think you're using the tree-like red
resolution is the same thing as a
decision tree
for the for the free equivalence i guess
between depth dt and
yes yes you can view this yes exactly
yeah
okay okay but
yeah but the results on the left-hand
side are much much more difficult to
prove
the the lifting theorems are definitely
more difficult to prove yes
yes oh and and i forgot to mention so
this this uh
improvement uh here uh was actually
improving the size of the gadget
so they got it down to almost linear
and and this is what actually um allows
you to obtain
the the size lower bound i mentioned
up to larger values of k the fact that
you actually have this
small gadget and this is this is a
yeah i think it's a very nice uh
improvement it uses this
sunflower lemmas and yeah
okay all right
okay
so if right so if we look at this this
middle
lifting theorem and now apply it
for search f where f is the pigeonhole
principle
we'll get the following so here we have
the
actually the graph pigeonhole principle
with k pigeons and k minus one holes
we're composing the search problem with
the indexing gadgets
and what the lifting theorem says is
that the size
of the protocol solving this is at least
m to the k
so this is this is what the lifting
theorem gives us
and here be okay the reason is that the
width required
to refute this in resolution is uh
i'm like okay if we if we consider an
expander for example so we'll be
considering the expander with the
degree three expander so the graph
digital principle means that you have a
graph
of degree three as you said that that
gives the possible edges for the visual
principle
exactly exactly yes yes
okay so what i would like to show is
that
how from this lifting theorem from this
result
we can obtain the click coloring
result so i want to show a reduction
from this composed problem to the
monotone kw game
of the click coloring function
and this will imply the monotone circuit
blur about
for click coloring by the kw relation
and then so i will show this reduction
but the same reduction also holds for
the search problem of the click coloring
formula
so the same reduction also gives us a
resolution lower bound for the click
coloring formula
so this is why the fact that pigeonhole
principle
is hard to prove or to prove implies
that
click coloring is is
hard to compute and also that click
coloring is hard to prove
okay so
now i'll focus on showing this reduction
okay so we have a pigeonhole principle
so here uh k equals five
so i have five pigeons uh
four holes and the pigeonhole principle
it has two types of clauses it has the
the pigeon clauses so this is pigeon
one can go to either hole one hole two
or hole three
so remember here we'll be considering
the degree three graph
and then we also have whole clauses that
say
that no two pigeons can go to the same
hole okay
so these are an example of a pigeon
clause and a whole clause
so for the this the search problem
composed with indexing
uh alice for for every variable so now
i'm only considering the
pigeon one variables uh
oh in case it wasn't clear so this z11
means that pigeon 1 flies to hole 1.
z12 that pigeon 1 applies to whole 2.
so alice for for each variable
alice has a next variable bob has a y
variable
and so bob's variables uh
each of these is a long string string of
length m
of zeros and ones and
alice's inputs are pointers to this
string
okay so this is the inputs they'll
receive
for the the search problem composed with
indexing
is going to be uh of this type
and now their goal is to construct uh
inputs construct graphs for the monotone
kw uh game of the of click coloring
so given these inputs they'll construct
graphs so these graphs still
for each of the k pigeons there will be
m cubed virtues
and bob will wants to construct an
input in the pre-image of zero so he
wants to construct a k-1
colorable graph and alice wants to
construct a
graph that contains a k-click so
something in the pre-image of one
and then we want to show that if they
find if they solve the monotone kw game
they'll be finding a falsified clause
so let's see how they construct these
graphs
so bob only has these very
long strings and he knows that alice's
inputs
point to somewhere in each of these
strings
so he'll consider all the m cubed
options
of where so for for each pigeon he'll
consider all the
m cubed options of where alice can be
pointing to so she has three pointers
and he has um strings of length m so
there are m cubed
uh combinations of possible places she
can be
pointing to so he considers all these
n-cubed options
and what what he would obtain from from
his strings
and each of these corresponds to a
possible assignment to the z variables
so for for example in the in here in the
first row
this corresponds to pigeon one flying to
hole one
so pigeon one flying to hole one the
second one corresponds to
pigeon one flying to hole three
and this third one actually corresponds
to pigeon one flying to both hole one
and hole two
and this fourth one corresponds to
pigeon not flying anywhere
i represent this with an x
so with bob only looking at his inputs
he can construct
uh well he can um yeah figure out
all of these possibilities of where
pigeon one can be flying to and he'll do
the same thing
for the other pigeons so pigeon two here
can fly to either hole one
two or four so when he looks at the
possibilities he'll
obtain either one two or four or or
nowhere
so by doing this for every pigeon
now he can color these graphs according
to
the whole so for example
every possibility of uh a pigeon flying
to
hole one hill color with one red
if it's flying yeah to hold three he's
coloring yellow
if it's flying to two holes it's getting
two colors
so here this is both red and blue
and now he adds an edge between
any two vertices in different blocks
that have different colors
so he'll add an edge here and so on
and if it if it has both blue and red he
only
uh he doesn't add an edge neither to red
vertices nor to blue vertices
so this graph is is going to be k minus
one colorable because it's colorable by
by the holes you never have an edge
between
uh two vertices with the same color
it also has some isolated vertices but
we we won't
those can be colored in any way we won't
color these so bob can construct a
k minus one colorable graph in this way
okay and now uh alice all she has is a
pointer
so for every pigeon
she knows that she's actually pointing
to
uh this position in in bob's
in this in all these m cubed
possibilities
so she looks at each of these uh
for every pigeon she looks at where
she's pointing to
marks those those vertices and now
she'll add an edge between all these
vertices
so she'll have exactly okay click
so now we have to see why if they solve
the monotone kw game
they'll actually be finding a falsified
clause
okay so there are two options
so suppose that they found
this edge which is present in alice's
graph but is not present
in bob's graph uh this can be because
uh these two vertices were colored with
the same color
in in bob's graph and
so what this means is that if it's
present in alice that alice was
actually pointing to these two positions
so it means if we if we apply the
indexing gadget
we'll get exactly these two positions so
in this case we'll get that
both pigeon 3 and pigeon 4 are flying to
the same hole
they're both flying to the green hole so
we found a
falsified hole clause
so this is one option another
possibility is that
there is no edge in bob's input because
one of these is an isolated vertex
so why is this so again alice's is
the fact that she has an uh an edge
means that she's actually pointing to
these two positions
so uh if this is an isolated
uh vertex that means that this pigeon is
not flying anywhere
so if it's not flying anywhere we know
that the pidgin
axiom is falsified
so by solving the monotone kw game
on these inputs that they generated they
can solve the falsified clause search
problem
of the of the composed
pigeonhole principle
okay okay so
this shows how uh the fact that
pigeonhole principle is hard
to prove implies that click coloring is
hard to compute
and and as i mentioned this also shows
that
um click coloring is hard
to to to refute
and yeah i think this is this is
interesting because
well i for one thought that
when you composed uh formulas
you would get something that was
artificial and
here's an example where you don't get
something artificial
and and i think the reason is that we
can actually
do the reduction in this communication
world so the fact that we can
reduce in the communication world allows
us to obtain
uh more natural formulas from lifting
okay are there any questions
so the number of colors is something
like uh
seven in this example or something like
that or no
it's it's four it's just the number of
holes
okay oh the number of colors is four yes
because bob had these dual colored red
yes these uh well we just think of them
being colored with both colors
but it's uh um yeah okay
so we're not assuming that something has
a unique color it only makes no no no
it's not a uni color it's it's
just colored with both colors it only
makes it easier to
solve yeah exactly and just like in
alice's case i guess if something maps
two places it's
a pigeon goes to two holes it's only
easier to
find a violation of digital principle
okay oh yeah exactly if a pigeon's going
to two holes it's only easier yeah
yeah exactly yeah
all right
okay you see
go on there's no other questions yet
okay
all right so um similar
reductions can give us so we saw
this one so we can get uh lower bound
for click coloring
we can also get lower bound for st
connectivity
by lifting or by this this gen function
uh this was generalization of sd
connectivity
so these can be obtained by um
by lifting and
there are also other applications of
lifting so we can get uh
circuit complexity separation so
i think the best separation between
monotone and non-monotone computation
is between it's an exponential
separation between monotone circuits and
then c2
uh also exponential separations between
monotone circuits and monotone formulas
also in this acnc
hierarchy we all these separations were
proved via via lifting theorets
we can also improve complexity
so as i mentioned so the second way of
obtaining cutting planes
uh lower bounds is via
lifting we can also obtain size-based
trade-offs
separations between proof systems so
here for an example where uh nussolin
sats is stronger than
cutting planes um also a
trade-off separation or a bounded space
separation between cutting planes and
cutting planes with bounded coefficients
so these are just some results that
where
we apply lifting
i also oh i didn't mention here but also
like proving automatability of cutting
planes was proved
also it required lifting
okay and and now finally some
uh just some open problems okay so we
saw some
connections between these objects
circuits proofs and communication
uh these are some sometimes um
very tight and we saw how this gives us
lower bounds or separations and both
proof and circuit complexity
and then just yeah some open problems so
i guess a very important open problem is
obtaining interpolation for stronger
proof systems
also um lifting for other communication
models
uh this could give lower bounds for
proof systems we don't know how to prove
lower bounds for
for example res lin or the stabbing
planes
also obtaining lower lifting theorems
with smaller gadgets
or even with other gadgets this
can allow us to obtain separation
between different systems
and finally i think a better
understanding of the relation of these
techniques and also the limit of these
techniques
and yeah that's it so thanks
all right thank you very much i'll
applaud on everyone's behalf
and since you can't applaud the
traditional sense um
so we're gonna take some time for
questions here
uh we've got about 15 minutes and
hopefully
we have fingers crossed we have a second
talk coming up in about 15 minutes also
um but let's let me open the floor to
questions
uh while we're waiting for people to
formulate the questions there's already
one
from massimo in the chat window
he asks does the reduction between
search problems
imply a syntactic reduction between
formulas
how is the formula g php plus induction
related to the formula clique versus
coloring
rat graph php plus induction related to
clique versus coloring
right right so that's a good question
yeah so um
uh i don't i don't know how to get the
synthetic reduction between the formulas
so if you if you consider the
the function the graph pigeonhole
principle
composed with indexing and look
look at this synthetically it doesn't
look
at least not exactly like click coloring
so so i think that it's
important to do this reduction in the so
yeah there might be some
substitution that you can do or
something to obtain
the click coloring but it's definitely
not not
direct
[Music]
does it apply for moscow it means you
have to go through the search problems
thanks yes yes i i mean yeah
at least that's the only way i know how
to get a nice reduction between two is
doing it in the communication
level so via the search problems yeah
okay um albert has a question
i can ask it for him if he wishes me to
or he can say it himself
so what about the contrapositive
has anyone discovered new proof of plexi
upper bounds from circuit
upper bounds versus media lifting
aha proof complexity
upper bounds from circuit upper bounds
via lifting
i don't know of any such example
i don't
yeah i i can't think of any such example
in principle it should be possible right
yes in principle
yes
here's one thing so right there is
this non-trivial upper bounds for clique
using matrix multiplication
right you can do a little bit better
than n to the k with
uh uh-huh this matrix not trigonal
matrix multiplication but of course
that's not monotone at all
i don't know might be worth looking at
it
right
can i ask you to clarify your next last
slide on the
um you listed all these
you said other applications so so first
of all i guess the
the g here you're composing with these
gadgets g is
always the same in indexing uh right so
yeah i didn't mention that the so i did
the reduction with indexing but it
actually holds for any gadgets there was
um indexing is kind of a universal
gadget
you can embed any gadget in indexing
so the reduction works for for any
gadgets
okay and
you gave this extremely nice
construction for the first
for the first reduction i guess of of
cleat coloring to
gphp's you have similar does the same
reduction work
same type of reduction work as
straightforwardly for everything yes
yes same type yeah
yeah yeah the same idea right
and then how how hard is it to get from
those
to the to all the results mentioned at
the bottom on cert on circuit complexity
separations and proof complexity results
and so on
uh-huh so some of these so for example
the monotone
circuits versus monotone formula this is
obtained exactly exactly for this
generation function
so this uses a lifting for pebbling
and then since we want to formula lower
bounds we can use
the lifting theorem that allows for very
small gadgets
and we can obtain a nearly exponential
separation between these two
so this follows from from this one
um others require composing with other
um i guess this
yeah some of these are are these
compositions so
um yeah this separation also has to do
with this
composing with pebbling but
and size-based trade-offs also but
cutting planes yeah size lower bounds
you need something harder so for example
yeah but this this is a pigeonhole
principle would be an option
so yeah some of these are or just
applications of this
i think that this uh new student sets
can be stronger than cutting planes you
need something
something like satan or need to compose
with something else
that's easy for new students that's
yeah but these are more or less uh
direct consequences of lifting theorems
okay very nice yeah one thing i forgot
to mention so the reduction i showed
doesn't exactly give the best
lower about dimension you need to change
it a little bit but
just so that's on the record but it's
almost exactly that
by the way does your reduction work for
a week
so when you have a separation between
the click size and the coloring
like a 2k click versus
k coloring or something like that yes
yes it should work right yeah yeah yeah
so the question is how far i mean how
much cap because the lower bounds we
have for a piece of hole
for the weak piece of horror are pretty
good right it's a huge
uh it's a huge gap i don't know what is
the gap in the click calling
uh-huh well the i guess one difference
is that
if if when you if you're gonna use an
expander you might
start needing no you still have small
degree in the pigeon side
yeah so
so i think it would work for
even with larger gaps yes okay
i think there's an open problem there
which is how far i mean the thing
the best upper bound for a weak piston
hole is something like two to the root
n and the best lower bound is like 2 to
the cube root n or something like that
ah yes this is a gap to be closed at one
point so maybe
maybe it can be close this way oh
whether you could get so here we were
getting uh click coloring lower bounds
from pigeonhole principle
so so not pigeonhole principle lower
bounce
yeah but maybe maybe that means it's not
possible because maybe
you cannot reach a lower bound of 2 to
the root n because there is an upper
bound for click coloring
of the of the corresponding gap
i don't know maybe it's easier to see it
directly but
since you have new insights it might be
uh-huh okay
yeah i'll think about this
but do do we have a lower bound
for the weak vision of principle or
graphs or
this was done recently by some people
jacob
who else is in that paper yeah dimitri's
sokolov killian and i
uh yeah so this
[Music]
this we can we can get up to
yeah for expanders they have to be
pretty good expanders but
but you can get their events
okay any other questions
i don't see anything in the chat window
but feel free to speak up
um okay otherwise let's see first of all
i'm very pleased to
say that our second speaker is here and
we'll be
we'll start in about five minutes we'll
save promptly at the half hour
and let's all thanks susana again for
really a very nice talk
and uh so it's great great to see these
results
so we'll take a five minute break and
start promptly again at the half hour
so so good all right thank you